we are not heading back to the 1970s
says the government this morning
well the government may not wish to head
back to the 1970s whenever he is
suggesting that they should what the
government should be doing is looking at
what they can do now to reduce the price
of food in our shops because of course
food inflation is running at a
significantly higher level than the
headline rate of inflation so let me
give you a couple of practical things
the government could be doing now
firstly they could be looking at the
Digital Services tax and that balance in
tax between the online Giants and our
bricks and mortar businesses and using
money from Raising Digital Services tax
to create a fund billion pound fund for
energy intensive Industries to make them
more readily able to produce food more
cheaply that's one thing they could do
secondly in my own area of trade they
could actually be negotiating a
Veterinary agreement for example with
the EU which would make it a lot easier
to import agri-foods from the EU so
there's two practical things the
government could do but above all what
the government needs to do in terms of
inflation is to provide political and
economic stability and that platform has
been sadly lacking from the
conservatives over the past 18 months as
we've turned through Prime Ministers and
that disastrous trustwateng mini budget
is it right to our supermarkets to cap
prices
uh I I don't think that that is the
right approach I think there are as I've
already indicated uh okay practical
things that the government can and
should be doing now I mean we've had in
the past in the the 60s and 70s
governments of both colors have looked
at this uh idea of trying to set prices
uh it's it's been been tried with mixed
success but what we need to see now in
the 2020s is the government actually
gripping the problems that we have and
offering practical Solutions Instead
This is a government when it comes down
to it take for example their recent
changes on the lifetime pensions
allowance instead of finding a specific
solution for doctors and the issue with
their pensions they gave this billion
pound tax break to the very richest when
it comes down to it and they have to
make choices this is not a government on
the side of ordinary families
um I'm sure you heard me asking early
here the um the government Minister
about a story that we've done here on
Sky News where parents were literally
stealing baby formula because they could
not afford to buy it because of the
massive increase in price and I asked
the minister whether someone caught
doing that whether they should uh face
uh the full weight of the law he said
it's up to each individual store what do
you think
well if somebody commits a crime and
they commit theft or shoplifting then I
think it's it's for the police uh
criminal justice system in terms of
holding them to account but the
government has to take responsibility
for the position that families up and
down the country find themselves in in
terms of putting food on the table yeah
I I visit food banks on a quite regular
basis the people who work there do an
absolutely tremendous job but it is a
national Scandal frankly that there are
so many food banks now after 13 years of
conservative rule the failure to grow
the economy the failure to improve any
of our public services so the government
has to take responsibility for tackling
the really high food inflation that's
affecting families up and down the
country
um just talk to me very quickly about
um brexit if you would in these new
trade deals um
the deer the deal that I'm looking at
giving a zero tariff trade on a lot of
uh Goods what would labor do to change
the trade deal with Australia and New
Zealand
so we have today the Australia and New
Zealand trade deals coming into effect I
think it is important that the country
having signed on the dotted line it now
sticks to what has been agreed but of
course we would have uh had a different
set of priorities there's trust for
example on the Australia trade deal set
a deadline against herself and then
sacrificed swathes of our agricultural
interests just to get a deal over the
line clearly we would drive a harder
bargain take the Australia trade deal
which we will now build upon we know
that there's a shared agenda with the
labor government in Australia to tackle
climate change create the green jobs of
the future we're going to want to deepen
that partnership but above all K what we
have to do whether it's these trade
deals or indeed other trade around the
world we have to support our exporters
here in the UK to take advantage of the
fact that tariff barriers are coming
down I've argued for climate export hubs
in nation and region of the UK working
with universities innovators of old
Administration so we can actually export
that climate technology of the future of
the world we need to stand beside our
exporters
what should baroness Hallett do if the
cabinet office doesn't hand over these
WhatsApp messages and Diaries by four
o'clock tomorrow afternoon
well look I I read very carefully what
uh baroness Hallett has said uh in her
notice she's got particular Powers as
the inquiry chair under you know it it's
under these section 21 Powers uh as
they're called but I read very carefully
what her views uh were about what the
cabinet office the government is is
claiming is not actually uh relevant and
it's clear from what she's written that
she's unimpressed by what they're saying
so far now the government has appointed
baroness Hamlet she's hugely respected
independent the government should be
respecting what Heather Hallett is
saying the government should be
complying with the orders that she makes
and they should be doing that firstly
because there are thousands of families
out there who've lost loved ones during
the covid pandemic who deserve to hear
the truth and not have a government
trying to run away from it but also
because we have to learn the lessons
from this health emergency for the
future so my my strong position is that
the government should listen to The
Independent chair that they themselves
appointed okay it's good to see you as
always hope to see you soon thank you
pleasure